welcome back to new rockstars I'm Erik
Bosse and Loki on Disney plus is one of
the most intriguing titles coming up on
the Marvel calendar with a hole two
seconds of an Easter Egg giving us hours
of discussion now rumors are swirling
that Loki could be linked with the new
Big Bad of the Marvel Cinematic Universe
the next Thanos to wreak havoc on a
grateful universe or a grateful
multiverse a time traveler by the name
of Kang the Conqueror
yeahyou non-comic Raiders can scoff all
you want but 10 years ago you would have
thought the name Thanos sounded stupid
too and now he's our Lord and Savior
with an ass that won't quit based on
what we know about the Loki series in
the way of interest in game left the MCU
Kang is actually an extremely likely
option for the next major threat facing
these characters I'm gonna explain who
this guy is and why you should care
about him spoiler warning in case I'm
too right and ruin your life okay so in
the first brief brief footage of Loki we
saw recently there was a critical clue
visible I have done this place to the
ground Loki is cuffed in a prison
jumpsuit stamped with the letters T DNA
which I explained in 9 beefy minutes of
another video stands for time variants
Authority essentially the Marvel
Universe is time cops the legal
enforcement agency for anyone who
disrupts timelines via time travel when
Loki escaped with the tesseract during
the time heist in endgame he created a
new branch timeline in which she was
still alive making him the loose thread
evidence not put back in place after the
Avengers meddled with time so that
probably makes Loki the target for the
TVA who are investigating this new
branch timeline that never should have
existed in the Marvel comics the primary
antagonist for the TVA is Kang the
Conqueror a time-traveling villain who
comes into conflict with pretty much
every group of Marvel heroes at some
point or another the Avengers the x-men
the Fantastic Four Kang has been
speculated to be a major new villain
introduced in the Loki series now from
what I can tell the origin of the
speculation is one of these
quote-unquote industry insiders who just
claim things without evidence so that
nerd blogs and channels will run with
them made - taken but the truth remains
that if you're going to bring the time
variants Authority into the MCU Kang
would definitely be part of that package
the TVA is like the Elmer Fudd - Kang's
Bugs Bunny because bugs is an immortal
tyrant on a mission to confound and
torture Elmer until
is that shotgun to end it all be barely
barely quiet voices inside my brain that
keep me for him sweeping well here's why
Kang could be so interesting to see as
the big bad of Marvel pays for Kang has
gone back in time over and over again
creating various versions of himself in
various caches of weapons and money to
keep his future self in power
essentially he pulled a Biff and
secretly dropped sports almanacs on
planet after planet to build up his
future resources these alternate Kang's
transcend timelines across the time
stream making Kang's super hard to kill
you have to go reality by reality to
undo every alteration he's made to cut
off the flow of resources to King Prime
who sits at the end of all time feeding
off of the various paradoxes he's
created Kane commands a whole dynasty
this way having built his empire across
the multiverse that butts heads with the
jurisdiction of the time variance
Authority and it requires super
brainiacs like vision like Reed Richards
with the assistance of various past eras
of Avengers all working in coordination
to eradicate this Kang dynasty in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe is now
expanding into a multiverse of ultimate
realities some via branch timelines
formed via time travel we actually
explained all the known components of
the multiverse in a recent episode of
the big question dad out but with Marvel
characters now existing across parallel
realities you need a big bad who can
terrorize all of them and create a
crisis so complex that even a time high
student clean it up we need a time heist
proof villain and that's Kang and
additionally Kang could open the door to
a new era of Avengers that Marvel seems
to want to introduce a face board so you
can see why these details are actually a
bigger deal than they seem if you were
just like read them in a tweet thank
goodness you had me shouting and jerking
my hands at you and your direction and
the reason I have this energy is thanks
to bang energy thanks to bank response
or in this video every can of bang is 16
ounces that's right no wimpy 12 ounce
cats here it contains 300 milligrams of
caffeine it's sugar-free and has zero
calories
it tastes great with over 20 different
flavors to choose from
this one's called froze a rose a and I'm
gonna froze a rose a every day because
there's a bachelorette party going on in
my mouth
yep a swig of bang fires up that nerd
brain of mine two-point mental red
arrows at the background details no one
else would see check out bang on
Instagram you can get 20% off your order
at bang energy calm when you use the
code new rock stars twenty five there
you can get a variety 12 back with a
dozen of their flavors flavors like pina
colada cotton candy birthday cake bash
and rose a rose a and thanks again to
Bank Energy for sponsoring this video
get 20% off at bank - energy commies in
the code new rock stars 25 and follow
the inventor of bang on instagram at
bang energy CEO so Kang the Conqueror
shows up in the Young Avengers comics
he's connected to the founder of The
Young Avengers iron lad now iron lad is
Nathaniel Richards a descendant of Reed
Richards from an alternate reality in
the 30th century he gets bullied almost
killed but King pops into existence of
last second and saves him and Nathaniel
learns that Kang the Conqueror is
actually a future version of him and
Nathaniel is horrified - the villain he
will become the villain who in various
different e's kills Avengers so he
battles his future self and then he
tumbles through the timestream to land
in present-day Marvel earth-616 there he
discovers The Avengers have dissolved
but he finds a recording a vision who
tells him about a fail-safe program to
rebuild the team and if they know
customizes his neuro kinetic armor from
the future to be an Iron Man colors and
become iron lad and he joins forces with
Hulk lean Wiccan and Asgardian they're
later joined by Hawkeye Kate Bishop and
Cassie Lang stature daughter of Scott
Lang so how could this look in the
upcoming MCU properties let's say that
Loki establishes Kang as a new arch
villain of the Marvel multiverse in a
lucid time traveler that keeps slipping
through the fingers of the time variants
Authority so the TVA offers Loki freedom
if he helps them track down Kang and
eradicate him and the resource caches
from the various timelines and time
periods that Kang is established in his
empire and at the same time of all this
one vision features Scarlet Witch
manifesting a reality in which she has
two children speed and Wiccan now we
have been assuming that Wan division
will be a version of the House of M
which ends with Wanda's kids fading from
existence but they kind of later get
reincarnated in a sense as speed and
Wiccan with Wiccan being part of the
Young Avengers and after both of these
seasons of streaming content will be
Doctor Strange in the multiverse of
madness a film that once had Scott
Derrickson as director promising a
horror inspired story with a possible
descent into hell but derrickson parted
ways with production over creative
differences and replaced by Sam Raimi
and Kevin Feige assigned Loki's
showrunner Mike Waldron to rewrite the
script for multiverse of madness so that
implies a stronger link between the
storylines of Loki and multiverse of
madness and if Kang is now the timeline
meddler behind Loki's mess he may now be
the same meddler that Doctor Strange now
has to try to outsmart spider-man 3
would be coming right after that in
summer 2021 and its predecessor
spider-man far from home teased an
Easter Egg of Avengers tower being
reconstructed into what many of us have
speculated is the Baxter building base
of operations for the Fantastic Four so
let's say spider-man 3 features the
fugitive Peter Parker taking refuge with
the new occupant of that Tower
a young Nathaniel Richards giving MCU
its first crossover to the Fantastic
Four the promise of a new generation of
Avengers and a villain that will take
several heroes working across several
films several streaming series several
timelines to stop from tearing the
fabric of the multiverse apart who do
you think the next Thanos of the MCS
should be and we've been digging into
this question and new rockstars official
discord where our team has been hashing
it out with our inner circle of
supporters join our discord today by
becoming a patron at patreon.com slash
new rockstars also comment down below
with your theories follow me on
instagram and twitter at EI vos follow
new rockstars and subscribe to new
rockstars here on YouTube for breakdowns
of everything you love thanks for
watching bye
[Music]